les nouvelles propositions du ministre
de l'éducation nationale en matière de
relations entre l'enseignement privé et
public
si elles sont relativement bien
accueilli ces nouvelles propositions par
les partisans du laïc
elles sont en général reçus par les
tenants du privé comme une sorte de mise
en liberté surveillée de l'école libre
alors pour nous rendre mieux compte de
l'impact de ces nouvelles propositions
nous avons envoyé ce matin notre
reporter claude crespo assister à
l'assemblée générale des chefs
d'établissement de l'enseignement libre
ils étaient plus d'un millier venus de
toutes les régions de france pour leur
assemblée annuelle mais présent surtout
pour discuter racho des propositions
savary l'enseignement libre cela
représente deux millions d'élèves 150me
enseignants et près de 2300
établissements fort de cette importance
il entend bien manifesté sa réprobation
en particulier sur la mise en place de
ip l'établissement l'intérêt public
une structure constituée d'un ou
plusieurs établissements privés de même
niveau auquel peuvent se joignent des
établissements publics
structure est essentiellement une
structure qui va permettre l'affectation
d'un certain nombre d'emplois publics et
donc à terme de fonctionnaires or nous
souhaitons garder une liberté
d'initiative et d'association or les ip
tel qu'il est présenté aujourd'hui ne
nous permet pas cette initiative privée
est alors la deuxième proposition contre
laquelle vous vous élevez c'est la
fonctionnarisation des enseignants
pourquoi est bien là encore c'est la
même logique
nous souhaitons que nos enseignants
puissent avoir la plus grande sécurité
d'emploi mais nous souhaitons aussi
pouvoir choisir nos enseignants avoir
des équipes éducatives cohérente et une
fonctionnarisation qui à terme serait
généralisé dans nos établissements
ferait que nos établissements
deviendrait purement et simplement
public
or cela nous ne pouvons l'admettre
première conséquence les partisans de
l'enseignement libre descendront dans la
rue entre le 22 janvier et le 4 mars des
manifestations composé de chefs
d'établissement d'enseignants des
parents d'élèves se dérouleront à
bordeaux lyon lille rennes et versailles
la suite